All right. Welcome everybody.
If you have your headphones on or maybe you
can hear my voice, uh, but, but thank you all for,
for being here.
This title of the, of this talk is, uh,
Build a multi-channel agentic Experience
with Twilio and AWS.
Uh, the first thing to point out is we have people from
both Twilio and AWS
on the stage. So this is a
collaborative effort. We've been working
together for the last year figuring out how to build
agentic solutions, how to build
cool stuff with both of our platforms,
and the talk today is, is the result
of, of that effort.
Uh, I'm Dan Bartlett. I'm a principal
solutions architect
at Twillo.
I'm Brandon Hawkins. I'm a lead PM at Tulio
for Voice AI,
and I'm Cameron Keene, a solution architect at
AWS.
Awesome. So that's the team again, Tulo and AWS
working together to, to make cool stuff.
Uh, I'm gonna read that title again.
Uh, build a multi-channel agentic
experience with Twilio
and AWS.
What does that really mean? We, we see agentic
on every, everything in the expo.
Um, I guess saying it in another way,
we wanted to show how
to build an application using
Twilio and AWS
that allows your users to interact
with the channel of their choice.
Uh, so, so the obvious channels
that we're gonna cover today are of course
voice,
uh, SMS, messaging,
uh, and email.
So, so that's what we've built.
Um, and, and also kind of allow them to
switch between the two, so we, we all
have kind of applications. Hey, it's a voice application or
it's an email application, but what about
being able to switch between the two channels, and
we think this is what people want
and certainly what is possible to build,
uh, with, with the tools that are available
today. Uh,
so what does this look like? Um, yeah, this
is probably one of the more
simple architectural diagrams,
uh, that you'll get this week, but, but really what we have
is we have your customers,
uh, talking to you or communicating
with you over voice, over
email, over messaging, you know, to
your application,
all backed, uh, by an LLM,
uh, so.
You know, it does get more complicated than
this, I promise, but if you don't remember
anything else from the slide, this is what
we're putting together.
Uh, so what are some of the principles
or what are some of the important points of a multi-channel
agentic application,
you know, what should it look like?
Uh, the 1st 3 are, I have
3 choices and, and a principle to kind of
out there, and, and the first choice is, is
channel, you know, we, we think that your customers,
your users wanna be able to use
voice messaging. There are different varieties of
voice, the different varieties of messaging
and email. We think email is a, is a great
channel. We'll talk about that more, but it's a
channel that that your customers wanna use.
Uh, choice with your speech
to text providers, your text
to speech providers, we think that's also important
because that might, that's gonna vary depending on your
needs
and same with, uh, with model with the
LLM model.
And lastly, kind of a principle and drive
you've done
been doing software development as long as me, you know, don't
repeat yourself. You should be able to build
this in a way, uh, that has, uh,
that has reusable components where all these
channels and all these models can, can work together.
Um, so what does this look like?
So this is kind of a conceptual diagram,
you know, that we
put together as we were kind of building this out. Like,
here are the different layers, and this is our opinion on
how we think
this can be built, uh, so with the intent
here is to have this be helpful for you guys
to have model your own applications. So kind of
going from the top down, it all starts
with your users, which is where it
should always start.
Uh, the next one is gonna be the channels.
Uh, so for us and for this talk that's
gonna be voice,
uh, messaging, uh, and, and email,
and then API layer is next. Uh,
you gotta have a way for bidirectional
communication, so the channels need to communicate
with you with your app. Your app needs to communicate
with the channels.
The meat of it is, is the, the centerpiece,
the agent application and data.
Are what you guys, you know, wanna concentrate
most of your time on, uh, so, so that's
your agent application. Uh, this is where
your business logic, uh, resides. This
is how you interact with the data,
uh, so certainly identity resolution
and context are, are important factors
when building these, these applications.
Uh, the agent framework, there's a lot of neat tools
out there that I'm sure you guys are aware of to kind
of help you build agentic experiences.
A service layer we'll talk about and and
lastly, you know, the model, the large language model.
Uh, these are the pieces that we
used for this
application. So now, of course we, we understand there may
be something different for what you guys wanna use,
but this is how we build it. This is our
recommendation on, on, on a solution.
Um, and we're gonna go through these all in
more details, but certainly you're recognizing the
channels from Twilio,
uh, the, all the different compute products and the
data products, uh, from AWS.
Uh, I will say this is an instance where our,
our segment product can be plugged in
for helping with, uh, all the user
focused data,
uh, and then agent frameworks and of course the models
down below.
Uh, so I'm gonna pass it over to, to Brandon.
There you go. I'm gonna hit the button for you. Thank you, Dan.
So this segues well into
what does Twilio do and why are we here. Let's
talk about that a little bit more.
This image, uh, that Dan showed is, is
relatively simple, but it's a lot harder
than it looks,
and, um,
businesses are struggling to build,
um,
amazing engagement, and it's, it's very hard to do that.
And these are, you know, 4 reasons why we think it's
hard to do that,
um, you know, consumer expectation has evolved.
They want brands to remember them across channels
and interactions, but that's very hard to do,
um. And that's because data
lives in different silos,
um, you know, and, and there's
fragmented experiences across these channels
the channels are in isolation like I said, and switching between
them breaks the continuity of the experience.
And third, there's so many tools, it's
difficult to create like a lifelong
conversation or that customer connection.
Um, you have signals from customers, from channels,
from AI, and they aren't unified or activated,
uh, in real time, and so that limits, you know, what
we can do and and what kind of customer outcomes we
can drive.
And lastly, builders have to, you know, we always have to
make trade-offs between
uh friction and security,
and uh you introduce risk and frustration in the
process. So
why Tullio?
Our mission is, uh, you know,
our vision is we envision a world in which every
digital interaction is amazing.
And we think we sit at an
interesting place in the ecosystem to
deliver value and deserve to play here.
We invented the CPSS category
17 years ago. We're the #1 leader
in the market for communications.
We are not a foundational AI company, but
Amazon is,
and we are a developer platform, so we partner
very closely with all of them
and and can make those technologies available
for communications use cases.
And then last but not least, you know, if we wanna talk about
personalization and personalization at scale,
we have to talk about contextual data.
So Tulio owns segment, which is a CDP
product that Dan mentioned,
um, but even if it's not our CD product, CDP
product, you need to have this information to have a
direct relationship with your customer.
Tulio sits right in the middle of that and so that's why
we think we deserve to be here.
And look,
this is just a slide with a lot of logos that show
you we are trusted by a lot of the biggest names
and brands in the industry,
um, you know, hundreds of thousands of customers
trust us to do all of their communications
with all of their customers.
And you know, look, most importantly, it's one
thing to be, you know, send a couple of messages here and
there. It's another thing to do this at scale,
uh, with 99.999%
uptime across the busiest periods of the
year. And so, you know, we just had our cyber
week, uh, last week and,
uh, and, and Black Friday, and we'll have updated numbers,
but from last year, you know, these numbers are pretty massive.
Um, you know,
over almost 5000 global
carrier connections,
partnerships with all of the big companies and names
in the business to deliver these messages,
um, you know, and hundreds of thousands of customers and global
reach and territory and scale.
So I'm gonna hand it back to Dan uh to dig into
each of these channels a little further and talk about how we
build with them on AWS.
Awesome, thanks, Brandon.
OK, so I mentioned the channels
today we're gonna cover in this application of voice
messaging and email.
And we're gonna start with voice, kind of the most
popular and the most exciting,
uh, channel, uh, that, that, uh,
people are building agentic experiences on.
Um,
hopefully you recognize this as the, the Twillo
logo.
Uh, does anybody kind of know where it's from? I
know you have your headsets on. Maybe make a symbol of,
of what it's from. I'll, I'll have Brandon do it.
So it's, it's from, uh, that's a universal
sign for, for a phone,
and, and this is, um, the
Twilla logo was, was inspired by
the kind of the receiving,
uh, the receiver of, of
handsets of old school landline phones.
So really our origins are in
voice in 2008, kind of when we
were founded, we were founded as a company
that uh enabled voice
calls for software. So we've
been doing this for a long time,
uh, we're certainly good at it.
Um,
the other thing to say about voice,
and there's a lot of people doing voice
applications, uh, Twilio, uh,
enables voice over multiple
different channels, so there's,
you can call them varieties of, of voice,
and it's important that you kind of recognize that and
kind of why Twilio can certainly help with
all your voice applications because there is
the existing SIP PBX.
Uh, telephony systems that enterprise
and companies have that are certainly
important and will remain important.
There's the good old, uh, PSTN public
switch telephone network that allows that's actually
the phone numbers that's an important channel,
uh, of, of voice.
And then also on websites, uh, Sulo
has been doing web RTC for
many years now, so 2011.
So to point to click on a website to actually
talk to a bot.
Uh, and then lastly with mobile SDKs,
so all these different variety of voices,
uh, of, of voice of the voice channel
need to be supportive or certainly should be
supportive, and you can get them all, uh, with, with Twilio.
Um, I'm gonna pass it back to Brandon. He's gonna
talk more about, uh, conversation relay
and kind of Twilio's offering in,
uh, voice AI.
Thanks again, Dan.
So funny we're starting with voice
uh when a few years ago people said voice
was dead and it's kind of having a resurgence.
It's interesting. 3 years ago, almost
exactly, Chat GPT came out
and we had customers, you know, who are more
tech forward come to us
and they were stitching together
a speech to text vendor, a text to speech vendor,
and putting an LLM in the middle and
throwing it on a call
and it was pretty good
and there's decent demos, but we kept hearing
three problems over and over again.
Um, if you're in this space, this shouldn't be,
uh, a surprise,
and, uh, chief among them is latency.
There's a subjective and objective component
to this, so
objectively we think
if the response time in a conversation
is, uh, more than 1 2nd, it's
weird. You hit the uncanny valley
of like, is this a robot? I'm talking to
an AI agent, you're slamming 0 to speak to
an operator,
uh, so that's no good.
So, um, latency is huge. There's also
subjective pieces, right? So when we talk to a
human. Uh, like we're doing now, I
would say, uh, or give me a second while
I look that up for you,
um, that has to be, uh, that has to
be handled as well.
The second thing we heard was inflexibility,
lots of point solutions, lots
of SAS startups, lots of VC money going into this
space, um, but Toyota is a developer
platform,
and
it's interesting for us as product people.
Uh, our customers want that absolute
control, and to turn every
knob to deliver a great customer experience
on their own, and they, they weren't seeing that in the market.
Last but not least is orchestration. This ties
back to latency with some of the subjective pieces
I was talking about.
Um, it's non-trivial but absolutely
mission critical to get this piece right.
You have to gracefully handle interruptions.
You have to have accurate turn taking
and know when someone's done talking and
when you should start listening.
Um, these are very hard to do, like I said, and you have
to get them right.
We've been doing this for literally 17 years.
Twilio exists in voice to orchestrate
real-time media.
So of course I've teed up all these problems and I'm gonna
tell you we have a solution that we're very proud about
and this is called conversation relay.
It's a bring your own AI
to Toyo voice. It's how you build
voice agents with Tullio,
and this went to general availability
in March.
It's one of our fastest maturing
products in Tulo history, and it's one of
our most, it's the, it's the area we see
the most overwhelming demand at the moment.
What is it?
Uh, of course I have the, the, you know, the bullet points
on the slide. We'll dig in a little bit more.
Um, it's a super low latency,
um, way of, of building Tulio of,
of voice agents on Tulio where you
keep the things that are differentiated for your
business, bring the LLM,
um, and we'll take care of all the orchestration,
all the unsexy parts,
uh, that we think are sexy about voice,
uh, and real-time media.
Of course we have some niceties like interruption handling
out of the box, and we have all the best vendors on the,
on the platform.
So we'll zoom out again an oversimplified,
you know, architectural diagram. I, I hesitate
to call it that in a conference like this.
Uh, what, what's going on here? What is it?
Uh, oversimplified, right? The left side
is Twilio, the right side is you,
OK? And so we have a web socket that sits
in the middle.
So if you imagine we're on a live phone call,
we're gonna transcribe, uh, the
voice into text,
send it over the web socket.
You will do something with it, presumably run
it through an LLM, you know, do data dips,
send us back the response,
and then we will speak it into the call,
and all of this will be done in super low latency.
The median latency is 0.5 seconds or
less,
and um you know we're gonna do this with,
with all these great things that we have baked into the platform
to make your life easier as a developer,
uh, interruption handling, DTMF built in,
and like I mentioned, a variety of different
choices for vendors on the speech to text
and text to speech.
If I could call out like two things here that I want to hammer
home. One is
give us the things that we do, that's
our business, that's non-core to
you, which is orchestrating voice, and
keep all the things on the right that
are differentiated, right, and be able to
switch between these new technologies as they come
out and have absolute control.
Also, you probably care about where this data lives.
You have absolute control of that this way.
I mentioned the vendors for speech to text and
text to speech that we have on the platform.
Um, I wanna talk about, uh, our strategy there
a little bit and, and why,
why this is interesting at all to, to talk about.
Uh, one is, of course,
look, the, the voice that
you present to your customers represents your brand,
so it's the singular touch point. It matters
a lot.
Our strategy was basically,
look, let's instead of
having everybody on our platform,
there's a new TTS vendor every week on
Product Hunt and.
We love all of them. Um,
let's instead take, you know, the advantages that
Tulio has with scale and put our
pricing and buying power into a
few that we think will go the distance.
And so what we've done is we've, you know, we've made bets on
the hyper scalers like Google and Amazon, of
course, but also the best of breed
startups in this space that, like I said, we think
will go the distance in Deepram and 11
labs.
And you know we've been able to make sizable
sizable commitments to these vendors
and you know that gets us insight into
roadmap and influence, but it also gets
lower pricing and we can pass that on to our customers.
One last thing to say about this is, um,
you know, because we've been concentrated
in our bets, if you will,
we've been able to co-locate these services
um where possible
so that we control uh
every piece of it, right? We can allocate
the GPUs that we think are appropriate,
uh, we're not sharing traffic with anyone else and of course
we deliver the lowest latency possible.
Um, and then the last thing to say about that, you know, that
goes back to, to this view
is. Why
can Tulio do this better in lower latency than
anyone else?
The call is already on our platform.
So right, we've co-located these services with
the call media edge. You're not taking additional
hops out to other clouds.
No one else can do that, right, because we're the provider of the
communication.
So we just go one level deeper like what's the developer
experience? How do you build with this thing? What's that look like?
Um, for folks who have built with Toyo
before, Twimmel is our Tulio markup language.
If you ever wondered how do you pronounce it, it's not Twemle.
We apologize, it was decided 17 years
ago. It's Twimmel,
uh, but this is how you do it, and
the way to think about this is this is your config,
right? So this is pre-run time.
What provider do I wanna use, what languages
are we speaking? What voice do I wanna use?
We can even automatically detect the language and
switch for you. Um, but that's your pre-setup,
right? Like what are we gonna do?
The magic happens on the right via
the service provider interface or SPI
fancy name of saying
we've defined some events that we will send
each other
live during the call
and this is really, really powerful so you know we'll
tell you there's an interruption, right, so you can manage the
context.
You can also change the language on the fly.
You can temporarily pause the ability to
interrupt. Maybe you need to play an
audio file that says
uh this call is being recorded for
you know whatever training purposes.
Um, there's a lot of really cool developer
niceties that are baked into the platform that we can do
in real time.
Last but not least, I'm not going to play the audio file
here, but we have a variety of fine tuning
controls. I've mentioned all of our customers really love
to turn all the knobs and dials.
This is very important when you're speaking to different
customers in different languages in different regions
that you don't butcher their name or a
product like a medical.
Product and so we have uh ability to
fine tune those those things with SML and
phonemes.
Um, an example here that you know
I won't share is, you know,
if, if we were in Ireland, which we were in,
uh, we were in London a few weeks ago giving
a talk, um, you know, we might have a friend named
Sheena and it's spelled S I N
E, um,
you know, if you don't use this,
uh, it will say Sine
or Sine,
but, uh, with this, uh,
control we can now say it, you know, correctly, Shina.
OK, so that was conversation relay.
Um, that's how you build voice AI agents on Twilio.
We talked a lot about the voice agent building
aspect. Now you've got it up and running,
it's talking to your customers, it's, it's, it's,
it's in, it's at scale.
Uh, now what? Well, the next thing you
should be caring about is observability, right?
We need to see inside the black box of automation.
And we think of this, uh, in
two different kind of pillars or buckets.
Uh, the first one is table stakes, metrics,
telemetry,
what was the latency, was their
jitter,
um, etc. etc.
It it, it sounds trivial, but you have to have those things
to debug and deliver a great experience.
The second is this more high level business
intelligence like what was the customer
sentiment,
um, was a competitor mentioned? Did
the, did the bot hallucinate,
and these are really powerful things that we could do
uh on Tulio.
And I'll walk you through like what are the names of those things at
Toleo and the products that we have.
Voice Insights is our flagship troubleshooting
product, um,
uh, and it's evolving from more of
a metrics, you know,
product to, to do really cool things like aggregation
and showing, uh, trends that are happening
across, uh, varieties of calls or different
customers or different regions.
You can measure end to end latency across text
to speech, speech to text,
uh, the network, etc.
And um you know this is now
available with conversation relay directly
integrated in a pilot
if you're Tullio customer, talk to your account rep we'll get you
access uh uh immediately, and
this will go uh more publicly available in
the the beginning of the year.
I also mentioned right this other side, this higher
level business intelligence. Let's talk about that for
a bit. So Tullio has a
product called Conversational intelligence. If
you've been a customer or aware of Tulo for a while,
we had sort of our own siloed data
problems where we had a messaging insights
product, a voice insights product, uh, a voice
intelligence product, and, um,
back in May again
this went GA as conversational intelligence
where we unified
an omni-channel intelligence observability
solution. Um, and
this is again, did the customer ask to be transferred?
Uh, did the bot hallucinate? Did the agent
achieve the desired goal?
And, um, super powerful using
a mix of pre-built language operators
and you can custom write your own.
Uh, we have LLM behind the scenes
and you could format the output through an API,
get events triggered exactly the way you want.
If you like UIs, we have this experience in the console,
you can do that too.
The one thing to call out here is that
this is all after the fact like
how does this work?
You have to have a transcript, so you have to have
a message that's in text you have to have a
voice call that's been transcribed you have to have the text,
right? And then we can run language operators on it,
um, and so you know, up until
now we've been very limited with regards
to uh how you can use it still
powerful
and we're very excited to announce here uh
on stage that it is now in the real time
domain and available on a pilot.
Uh, and it will be more publicly available at
the beginning of next year.
So now that we can do this, we can run these operators
in real time, right? And that's very, very powerful
in terms of, uh, automating AI agent
experiences,
um, AB testing against your humans,
and um we're really excited about this.
OK, before I give it back to Dan, um,
we, we, we had, uh,
we've gotten a lot of questions and we kinda wanna ad lib
here just a second if you, if you give me some grace,
uh, uh, during the week about,
hey, you guys are talking a lot about voice AI agents,
you're talking about speech to text, text to
speech. What about speech to speech?
I've heard this is a thing.
What about multi-modal models? So let's, let's
talk about that for just a second. Um,
I am personally as excited about it as, as
many of you might be.
Um, the promise,
let me back up just a second.
The text to speech, speech to text architecture
is called the cascade model,
uh, because we're cascading through the pipeline,
and this new speech to speech model
eliminates text to speech and speech to
text so the the LLM does it all,
right? It's expanded to do both, both sides
uh of the of the coin.
This is exciting because, uh,
right, theoretically you have the
lowest possible latency because you've eliminated
parts of the, the pipe.
Um, it eliminates complexity as well.
But it, but it preserves uh
sentiment and, and tone
and um emotion better because
it stays in audio.
The LLM can process audio directly.
Um,
and so that's very exciting. It's very promising.
So what I would want to say on this is it's very early
days. Tullio always, you know, especially
as a product person, we always wanna be able to
say yes to customers. So if a customer wants to
come and build on us and you want to use the latest
and greatest, we're gonna say yes.
So we have a product in this space
that's also in pilot,
and, um, and we're really excited about that.
We wanna be ready
because the second thing, which is the takeaway,
is we don't think it's ready yet.
Super excited. It's not the recommended
way of going to production at scale
with voice AI agents yet,
and the primary reason for that is that businesses
run on text.
And so if you need to prevent the bot from hallucinating
or you know speaking something you don't want said into
the call, you cannot interrupt that if it's
an audio stream.
And if you do, it'll say something before you can
stop it.
Some other reasons are it's very expensive,
although I think we know how technology works that will come
down over time.
And um you know
you you have less control
because you're locked into a particular ecosystem.
So with the Cascade model you could pick a TTS vendor,
you could pick an STT vendor,
you could pick a communications vendor, you could pick
an LLM.
So if you go speech to speech you're all in
on the LLM,
right? You don't have the, you have the choices they have and
that's what you get.
I'm gonna speak out of both sides of my mouth again. We're
excited about it. It's just not there yet
and so I'm gonna leave you with when that
day comes, we have a product and we will, we
will be ready for it.
All right, I won't opine anymore about the future
of tech. Uh, let me hand it back over to Dan
and Cameron to talk about how do we actually
build these production scale systems on,
uh, ADS and Toyo today. Awesome, thanks,
Brandon. Uh, so Brandon showed
a high level architecture diagram. This
is a little bit deeper. It's been on the screen for
a little bit. Uh, but essentially a
call comes in from the Twilio platform.
This is a post call.
It goes to your application where it
then goes back and it initiates that
conversation relay session. That's the web socket
speech to text, text to speech cascade
model that Brandon talked about.
Uh, the text is sent back to your
application where you're gonna get context and you're gonna
get. Uh, your interaction with the
prompt and, and with Bedrock,
you're gonna send the stream the text back to
conversation relay and where we turn that text
into speech.
Uh, so we, we'll go even further later in
the talk, uh, with the architecture diagram.
Also we'll mention that this works with
certainly other any compute. So you, we've, we've
built this using EC2. We built
this using containers. So a lot of options here.
We're hoping to kind of give you guys some guidance on, on
how you could build your own solution.
Uh, all right, so let's get to a, a, a demo
and, and Cameron's been here for a little while. Cameron,
you're ready? Yep. All right, there you go. All
right, thanks, Sam.
All right, so you've seen a lot.
uh Dan showed us the architecture diagram.
Brandon talked about conversation relay.
So, let's actually see what an application looks
like using both conversation relay
and the AWS infrastructure.
So here I have a conversational helper
bot to give you information about reinvent.
So let's take a listen.
Hello, I'm Reinvent 2025 Helperbot.
How can I help you today?
Can you tell me about the replay party? I heard a lot
about dodgeball.
OK, let me look into the details of the replay
party for you.
The replay party is a big end of conference
celebration on Thursday, December 4th
from 7:30 p.m. to midnight at the Las
Vegas Festival Grounds. Some of the key details.
Entertainment. Two main stages with live
bands, a silent disco with AR
integration activities dodgeball,
button mash, ping pong, enhanced
giant maze,
interactive AI zone roller skating, amenities,
sustainable menu options, craft cocktails,
themed lounges,
complimentary shuttle service from R,
Invent hotels starting at 7 p.m. The
dodgeball activity sounds like it will be a lot of
fun. Let me know if you need any other details
about the replay party.
Yeah, that sounds great, but I actually need to go
learn something first before having fun at the replay
party. OK,
got it. Let's take a look at some of the learning sessions
you might be interested in before the replay party.
Based on your interest in serverless, here are
some recommended tell me about Mandalay
Bay on Thursday.
OK, let me check on the Mandalay Bay venue
and any sessions happening there on Thursday.
Based on the search results, it looks like there
are a few sessions happening at the Mandalay Bay
venue on Thursday, December 4th, 10:30
a.m. How Samsung optimized 1.2
PB on Amazon Dynamo DB with zero
downtime, lightning talk,
3:30 p.m.
Slick Deal's AI powered deal discovery with
Amazon Sage Maker,
Lightning Talk,
4:30 p.m. simplified data
lake access with AWS Identity
Center, Lightning Talk,
the Mandalay Bay.
Lightning Theater seems to be hosting a number of the
shorter 20 minute lightning talk sessions on
Thursday.
Yeah, let me know if I want to attend that sage maker session.
OK, got it. The Sagemaker session you're
interested in is the session you're interested
in is SMB 206 vertical
bar,
lightning talk,
vertical bar,
slick deals AI powered deal text me all this
information. OK,
let me summarize the key details about the Sage
maker session you're interested in and send
them to you via text.
Done. I've sent that to you.
Is there anything else I can help you with?
Nope, that's it.
OK, no problem.
OK, so what did we just see?
We saw dual channel streaming between
conversation relay that converted speech to text
and text to speech
between an AI agent running on an EC2
using Bedrock.
As you can see, I asked the questions about the replay
party. It knew
the details about the replay party. I asked about sessions.
It gave me a list of sessions. I could dive deeper
on specific locations,
times and dates.
And then I asked,
OK, this is great, but can you send me a text message
so I can save this for later.
So we're able to induce using
voice, text and email a
seamless multi-channel experience achieving
subsecond latency on that.
So let's dive a little deeper on agents.
So agents in a nutshell.
So, as you saw,
uh, we had a prompt for our agent, so it's a helper
agent where we define goals and instructions
on
being a helpful assistant to the replay party
to give details about sessions,
about the replay party and just reinvent in general.
And then beyond that we had tools, so
as we saw it sent us a text message.
So we have 3
different voice channel tools
we have SMS, we have voice,
and we have email
and so when I said hey please send me a text message,
the agent recognized the
user was referencing the SMS tool
and it was able to send a text message in the background
without exiting the main voice conversation.
And then we have our context
where I started diving deeper on
the sessions and the specific locations
and we have a knowledge based
tool running
asynchronous as well to look
up in your knowledge base defined in Bedrock.
So let me dive.
So this is like a high level architecture diagram
of the agent itself.
So as I mentioned, we had 4 tools. We had our 4
communication channel tools
text, call, and email
where users can say, hey, send me a text,
or can you call me with this information,
or can you send me an email, as you'll see later in our
demos
and then we have the knowledge-based search tool.
So why do we have
these 4 tools as separate tools and not
built in within the agent?
So in a main voice product like this,
achieving subsecond latency
is the main
challenge,
so we wanted to
Define tools as asynchronous tool calls
to not block the main communication channel.
And the same thing with the knowledge-based search and the other channels.
So this is great, but this seems
very complex.
And so
managing the context, managing tools,
if you start going multi-agent, how do you
orchestrate it and the collaboration between the two?
This is where open source frameworks come into
play, so we have strands, we
have lang chain, lane graph and crew
AI. They help do the heavy lifting
of writing all the manual code you have
to do to manage this.
OK, this is great. You're able to build your agents
to do all the tasks you need,
but where do you go from there?
How do you host this at scale?
And that's where Agent Core comes into play.
So we showed our previous architecture
with EC2.
So if you still wanna run them on your own hosted
infrastructure, you can,
but with the new launches and Agent core runtime
with dual channel streaming, this enables
this entire architecture that you saw earlier to
also be deployed on Agent Core,
uh, the entire Agent core family.
So we have our framework that we built
uh in Lang chain in the previous example
and then we can deploy that to agent core runtime.
And with the
The new release of dual channel streaming with web
sockets, it allows us to have that low latency
connection.
After that, we provide the model choice
using the new Nova 2 models,
the freshly launched Gemini models, and the
latest cloud models.
After that we have memory.
This will handle
all the session management
and context for you,
so we have short term and long term memory to
store sessions for less than 30
days. So the conversation I just had would be in
short term memory
and then once you hit the 30 day window,
it gets uh summarized and stored
in long term memory to persist user
context.
And then within the AWS environment,
observability for your agent,
so knowing what the agent's doing,
seeing the token usage, latency,
that's where observability comes into play.
And then if you have existing functionality,
if you have lambda functions, existing code that you
wrote, or you have APIs
that you already have built,
agent core gateway
allows us to put an MCP layer on
top of those,
uh, APIs and lambda functions
and allow your agent to use that without having to rewrite
your code for agents.
And then we have messaging,
so let's take a look at a messaging
demo as well.
So just to recap, we had a voice
conversation that sent me this text message about
the age maker session.
This is great,
but I'm sitting in the session right now
and I can't take a voice call.
So I do have another question
that I want to ask the helper assistant.
So I follow up in this channel on how
do I get to the replay party. I heard the replay
party is at the fairgrounds. That
sounds really far away. My feet hurt from walking all
day between.
My hotel and the expo hall
and I don't wanna have to walk there
so I sent a text message, hey, how do I get to the replay
party from the Mandalay Bay.
I don't want to walk
And then
within a few seconds we get a text message response back
saying there's a complimentary shuttle
from
reinvent
the expo hall to the replay
party. And then I said great,
can you send me an email with this information?
So it'll send me a summary of
the session information
and it'll
tell me about how do I get to the replay
party from the Mandalay Bay.
So I finish up and fire off this text here.
And then
it lets me know that it sent me a text
message. Uh, sorry, excuse
me, that it sent me an email
in the same thread.
So here's the email. I'm opening up the email
as we see it texted me about the
stage maker session I was asking about
and the replay party and and how to
get there. So
that is the messaging
to email uh
seamless experience.
And now I pass this on to Dan to keep talking
about messaging. Awesome,
really cool. Thanks, Cameron.
Uh, so we just saw how you can easily
switch from voice to
SMS,
uh, and continue the conversation
with the context, uh, preserved,
and I wanna just pause here on SMS
and messaging, uh, in, in general
because this is something that Twilio also does,
you know, really well,
uh, but mess messaging is, is certainly
complicated with compliance and
global numbers and sender types.
It, it is something that you really need a
good partner.
To make it more simple.
Um,
what type of sender do you have? What type of throughput do you need?
These are things that are hard questions, uh,
but Twilio certainly makes it, makes it easier.
Uh, we're throwing up some stuff from Cyber Week
last year. We have, do have our numbers blew
from last week. They, we blew those numbers out, you
know, we do have
a massive scale,
uh, and we can be the, the trusted provider,
uh, in order to handle your, your messaging
volume.
Um, we talked about SMS, we talked
about MMS,
and those are cool. That's what's kind of people
are used to using, but I
would be remiss to not also talk
about RCS, uh, and
if you're in this space, you may know what RCS
is,
uh, but if you're not, it stands for Rich Communication Services.
It's been in planning for a number of years
now, like 10 years I think it's, it's, it's
been in, in spec, maybe even longer than that.
But it's finally gotten wings and
Tweely was on boarding customers
to RCS, you know, today and, and it is
in production use,
you know, what is it? What, what is it different? What's different
about it? The first thing is gonna be,
you know, the branding and verification. So
in order to get a message, you know, from
a business, you do get the actual
logo and the brand and
the verification. So a big deal as far as
people knowing that they can trust the sender.
Uh, the second one is
about the rich content that
becomes available in RCS
and again pointing out RCS is available
in your native application,
so they don't need another application. This stuff is all
delivered through the iOS
or Android device as long as it has
kind of the most up to-date operating system.
Uh, but this type of interaction, so with,
with content with, with video
and rich carousels and cards,
you make a, a huge difference
from the user experience point of view.
But, but not only that, there's, there's also called to actions,
uh, so think,
uh, quick reply buttons, uh,
think, uh,
carousels, think other widgets
like wallet and calendar. These
things all are now available
with RCS and they're super cool, but think
of that combining them.
With, uh, agentic
capabilities, so allowing your agent
to, to send a quick reply button,
allowing them to send a carousel or a calendar
reply, there's a lot of neat things that are opening
up and then again combine that with a voice
conversation and switching to
SMS and messaging and email.
There's the, the possibilities, you know,
with this new capability are really exciting
and Twilio can help power them.
I also want to point out that what
everything I just said about RCS and what
uh agents can do as far as sending rich
content and interactive content
is also possible
with WhatsApp
and many people from Reinventor from
around the globe where WhatsApp is a
primary channel. It is the preferred
channel,
and Twilio is a top provider of, of
meta for for meta and WhatsApp, uh,
globally. So just another channel that's, that's,
that's available kind of as we were talking about voice.
As different varieties where you might have
SIP and Web RTC
and the PSTN phone number, the same is
true of messaging and you wanna be able to offer
the messaging channel of choice. RCS
where it's available, fall back to SMS.
People prefer WhatsApp. You should have that available
too. Uh, last
thing too, while we're talking about WhatsApp
and going back to voice, we do have
WhatsApp business calling
available on the Twilio platform too, and that is
being rolled out
another exciting variety
or version of voice so that you can also
make available
for your agentic uh applications.
OK, so we've made it through,
uh, two channels so far.
Uh, so email is the last one,
and email's been around for a while.
Um,
these are again our numbers
from 2024.
Uh, the 2025 numbers are, are bigger than
this. You know, you know,
Senrid
Twilio Senrid powers tons of
business emails, you know, every day and,
and certainly,
uh, globally.
Um, you know,
email has been around for a while. My kids
tell me that your email is, is, is
kind of the old person's channel, but I actually
don't believe that.
Uh, I think email is something that everybody has.
Uh, everybody is, it's ubiquitous.
It's, it's, uh, something that.
Allows for richer input and
richer output
and I think, and a lot of people share this belief
it is primed to be a, a
major channel and agentic applications
as well you know I think voice is getting
attention you see messaging.
I think email is, is really
one that that folks should look at and I think
folks, you know, will look at.
Um, so we, let's see a demo on,
uh, email.
Oh OK, throwing a little
curveball at you.
AI does some weird things.
Uh, we, we thought we'd lighten it up a
little bit. You may recognize that
movie trailer or image from
a popular movie, movie about three
people,
uh, that were in Vegas and, and got into
a little trouble.
Uh, so that is the theme of
the last part of our demo that I'll
pass over to Cameron.
There you go, Cameron.
All right, thanks, Dan.
So let's see our 3rd email demo here.
So I must
have went just to recap, what do we see? So we had
our voice conversation
that sent us a text message.
We had our text
demo sending us an email,
and now we're seeing email to email containing
the same
session history between the two.
So let me click into this email from yesterday, so we're jumping into
the future here.
I must have been went way too hard at the
replay party last night. I don't remember what happened.
I don't even remember what sessions I went to yesterday
and I lost my wallet. So let me follow
up in this email thread that I got sent
yesterday asking
to help me retrace my steps and help me find my wallet.
So I send that over
to the email here.
And
it should
contain the session
information from all the three channels.
So we send this off
and then with a few seconds we get an email response
back with the
summary of
what we did.
So we'll open this up here and we'll go through it.
So it says earlier in the day I attended
a Sagemaker session.
Now that's starting to come back to me. I remember something on
Stage Maker at the Mandalay Bay,
and then it says I went to the replay party.
OK, so how did I get there? It says I took
the shuttle from Mandalay Bay. OK, great,
and then.
Um, I enjoyed dodgeball, um.
Maybe that's why my next little sore maybe I got hit in
the head by a dodgeball or I had too much to drink,
not really sure,
um. So as you can see, it's retracing
my steps to the 3 conversations I had.
So when I asked about the replay party and I mentioned I was interested
in dodgeball, it brings that up here.
Uh, when I asked about the Mandalay Bay session,
it brings that up here as well,
and then it recommends some steps on
how I should follow up,
uh, finding my wallet.
So now we'll pass this back off to Dan. Awesome,
thanks, Cameron.
I, I'm sorry about the rough night you're
gonna have tonight.
Um, just kind of re-emphasizing
what, what we've seen with these demos,
made a, a, a voice call, you
know, in,
uh, was solved with the, with the agent.
Uh, all of the context of that call
was preserved.
Uh, then we moved to SMS,
added more context, and requested more
information, we got that back, and
then thirdly we switched to email
and asked a question, and, and the context from
the entire conversation across all those
channels was preserved.
So it's a pretty neat stuff and, and this is something
that we have built
and we are gonna make available to you guys. This is
the type of thing that you can build today.
Uh, and we're certainly using, you know, the Twilio
platform and tools available with AWS
is going to allow you to do that
to make it, make it easier.
We saw this image before,
uh, the users at the top, the Twilio
channels, you know, of course conversation relays
are supercharged
version, uh, of that that's available
for the voice channel,
uh, the APIs that we saw, the
application layer, the data context layer, uh,
Cameron talked about.
The frameworks that are available certainly make it
easier to build out these agents. Uh,
the bedrock services MCP
is something that is, is
in one of the slides that Cameron had too.
And then lastly, you know, the models.
So exciting stuff. This is the high level,
and we did promise you another, uh,
more complicated
diagram, uh, that we can
walk through and, and this is again what, what we
have built and, and we are gonna make this
available for you folks all to
spin up too.
And we'll spend a little bit of time and we're, we're, we're,
uh, coming towards the end of it, but I'll let Cameron
go first and, and talk about the AWF's
side of, uh, this architecture,
all right. So,
We have these 3 channels from Twilio, where
they're using web sockets and API requests.
These all enter through Route 53 of our
network. So the main, the first
step is getting your domain set up
and setting up your web socket connections,
uh, certificates.
We need secure connections to connect to
programmable voice with conversation relay.
You can't just use a normal web socket, it has to be secure.
We drive all the traffic in through our internet gateway,
so we have all of our networking with our low balancing
between our two availability zones.
So the key here is
is co-locating your region closest
to your customers
to improve the latency.
And then doing a minimum of 2 availability
zones within your VPC to
reliably handle all the traffic.
So we have our load balancing
in our net gateway.
Into our EC2 instances.
So in this app, this demo you saw,
we have EC2 instances within auto
scaling groups
that are running the server that uses the web
socket connections to drive the dual
channel
streaming with conversation relay.
And so conversation relay synthesizes
the speech to text.
The text gets passed into our AC2
instance running our server that
calls Bedrock.
So Bedrock, uh,
the EC2s are hosting the agents
and then we.
Called Converse stream for two-way streaming
with Bedrock.
Within Bedrock we're also using knowledge bases,
so that's where the S3 bucket comes into play here.
So in this design we have every
single session as an individual JSON
object that has the date,
time, location, and general description
of each session
stored in S3 bucket.
We use open search to vectorize that
into our knowledge base hosted in Bedrock
and then we have our converse stream conversation as
I mentioned and then we have the knowledge base tool
that's a asynchronous tool call
using invoke Bedrock to run in the
background because Converse stream does not
natively support knowledge-based integration.
So that's why we have a separately defined tool
using the normal invoke Bedrock
with the knowledge base ID
to get more information about our sessions.
And then for session persistence,
we have Dynamo DB to store the
sessions between users
and the uh conversation
history. And then as you
saw where we had the web RTC with
the demo.
That was just hosted on Amplify with a simple react
application using WebSockets to stream
the audio to our
Amplify application.
And now Dan will talk about the Twitter side.
Yeah, thanks, Cameron.
Yeah, so
On the Twilio side we have,
uh, the things that we've covered here, but, but again
kind of similar with leveraging all the, the
platform capabilities of AWS
you can do the same with Twilio and take advantage
of our platform capabilities
and security compliance dashboard.
Brandon showed about some of the, the voice insights,
what's available there, but that's available
across all of your channels.
Benefit of kind of consolidating on, on a
platform. And the enterprise grade
tools and kind of our super network capabilities
that Twilio offers the global reach
being kind of the most pertinent one or
one of the most pertinent ones.
Um, the channels we've covered all of these,
uh, so programmable voice, we started
there again pointing out the different varieties
so you have
good old fashioned telephone numbers, web RTC,
you know, SIP,
and, and WhatsApp.
Uh, programmable messaging with SMS,
we talked about, uh, WhatsApp. We've
talked about RCS, and we talked about
chat.
All of these channels can be accessed
through the same program, uh, programmable
messaging API. So you're writing your
code in one way and leveraging
all these channels. The same is certainly true
with voice.
And lastly with, with email, uh,
also
with our Serid product,
straightforward all within the same Twilio platform.
And I'm gonna point out to here
the the post here from all three of these,
so the interaction goes through a single endpoint.
So just kind of stressing how cool we think this
is, is you have all of the
interactions that are coming from
Twillo in order for, for inbound
communications, whether that's an inbound call,
an inbound message, an inbound email
are going to the same endpoint through the
same application
and likewise that same application is
is able to post back.
Uh, of course, the voice
agentic application is gonna use what's,
uh, web sockets
because that's required certainly for latency,
but you have a simplified architecture, a
more simplified architecture for a pretty
complex application if you think about it. There's a
ton going on here.
But what the the the combined
architecture platform capabilities of
Twilio and AWS really
takes a lot of that
undifferentiated heavy lifting off
of your hands and and puts it over to us
allowing you all to to focus on the
application part of that.
Uh, so we're excited about this again.
It is a blog, uh, that is coming out
so that hopefully you guys will, will, uh,
look for that and, and spin it up on your own
environments, and I'm gonna pass it to Brandon.
Awesome. Thanks Dan. Thanks Cameron.
And so to bring us home,
uh, presentation run 101, you,
you tell them what you're gonna tell them. You tell them
and you tell them what you told them.
Uh, we talked about how, look,
it's very hard to deliver communications
at scale to deliver great customer experiences
across all these different communications channels,
um, and how Twilio and Amazon can
come together
to make that easier,
uh, and us being together is better together. Um,
to make this happen at scale, we started very
simple, uh, at the beginning, and we got,
uh, much more, uh, production scale in
terms of the technicality of the, the architecture
and like Dan mentioned, we have more coming so that you
don't have to,
you can take a picture, but we'll post a blog
and you can go and build these things yourself.
We also talked a lot about what we have
today, what can we sell today? What can you go and
buy today.
Um, and if you wanna come and hear about
what you can buy tomorrow and what the future
might be, you can come and go across the bridge
and go to the Venetian to the expo hall and talk to
us at our booth.
So thank you everybody for coming. Thank you, Dan and Cameron,
and we'll talk to you soon. Thank you.